Hi, in this video we will see how
computers talk. Before we do that, I would
like to give you an analogy of how
people talk. In this room we have John,
Bob, and Mary, and when John wants to
talk to Mary he says, "Hi, Mary! This is John.
How are you doing?" Now, when they're in the same room
they're sharing the same medium, which is the air and all of them, Bob and Mary
hear (listen) to this message but only Mary
responds because it's addressed to
Mary. In the same way, when computers
want to talk they share a medium. In this
example all these three computers are
sharing a cable. This is how networks
were built in the past so you have NIC
cards for each of these computers and
they have their own MAC addresses. Now,
let's say if A wants to talk to B, what
A does is it sends a message to B
which looks similar to this:
"Hey B, you know you use the MAC address to address B, this is A talking and here
is my message:
"How are you doing?" Now, when this message
is put on this medium everybody on this
medium can listen to it. So in this case
B and C can listen to this message.
Now what happens is, when C looks at
this message it sees that it's
addressed to B so just silently ignores
it and B, when it gets this message,
it sees that 'Oh! This message is
addressed to me, so let me reply" and when
it decides to reply what B does is: "I
want to know who is talking" so, it looks
like the original message and sees it's
A who is talking, so it says "Hey,
A, this is B" and the actual message "I'm
doing good"
that's how computer talk.